the knights are already two games into
their 2021 season the silver knights are
about three weeks away from starting
theirs
first ever practice though today over at
lifeguard arena in henderson
most of the players you'll see this
season in the american hockey league
were on the ice today
silver knights might have the best of
both worlds a committed owner to winning
here
a parent club 30 minutes away a home
training facility that is second to none
now for these guys
everything here to be successful you
know just driving around the city seeing
golden knights license plates almost
everywhere you go and
you know even getting to wear this logo
on our hats for now at least
it's really cool it's a i think this is
uh this has turned into hockey city
i think they've done a great job and the
organization as a whole and
uh making us feel like we're important
down here and they built this brand new
facility for us which is
which is amazing and they're building a
brand new uh home rank i think it's
supposed to open next year so without
seeing a whole lot of the other american
occult rinks or facilities
and talking to some of the players is by
far the best in the league here
silver knights are expected to release
their schedule soon their season starts
as we mentioned about three weeks from
now
this is